esto ocurrió durante una redada del
ejército israelí de las que vienen
siendo habituales en yenín en la zona
norte de la cisjordania ocupada allí la
veterana periodista palestina en jardín
agua que fue asesinada por un disparo
y su compañero área de salud y que se
encuentra estable también sufrió heridas
en la espalda según el propio al samu de
testigos como un fotógrafo de la agencia
afp
agua que le fue alcanzada por una bala
de las fuerzas israelíes al ser muy
explicó que en ese momento no había
intercambio de disparos en presencia de
civiles ni palestinos armados y que por
el contrario estaban identificados con
cascos y chalecos de prensa y aún así
fueron atacados esta descripción fue
discutida por el gobierno israelí que
sacó su propia versión de los hechos en
un comunicado el primer ministro de no
estar y bennett dijo que es probable que
la periodista haya sido alcanzada por
fuego de milicianos palestinos que en
ese momento según él estaban disparando
de manera indiscriminada ofrecieron un
vídeo como prueba de menos de 14
segundos en el que se observa a un
palestino
celebrando haber derribado a un soldado
cuando en realidad no han sufrido bajas
sin embargo este es un vídeo que no
puede ser una prueba fuerte si se tiene
en cuenta que no se puede constatar que
sea el mismo lugar en el que ocurrió la
muerte de agua que cni y que no coincide
con las versiones de quienes estuvieron
presentes